hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the speed Chess
Championship quarterfinals it is the
matchy karunakamura versus levonne
arunyan you can see that Hikaru is rated
2909 which is absolutely incredible and
that of course means that he's playing
uh incredibly well but it's not just
that he plays uh speed just while he
also plays classical chess well so he's
uh he's a very well rounded player in
any time format but so is Lavon so this
should be an excellent match uh let's
check out one of the games and then we
are going to discuss what happened in
the match this is game seven it is the
most requested one so I'm showing this
one first sorry about the C on the bird
sometimes uh I do change it but I forget
to actually update the interface so give
me just a few seconds there we go
uh so it doesn't get confusing as this
is a speeches championship and this is
from the five plus one section like we
say in every video when we are covering
this it's a hour and a half of five plus
one then 60 Minutes of three plus one
and then 30 minutes of one plus one uh
the so-called slow bullet and now let's
check out the game it's quite a nice one
and you will very quickly uh see why we
have quantity for by Hikaru D5 by Levon
Knight to F3 Knight to F6 and now Pawn
to E3 the so-called call system C5 by
Levon and not D captures and C5 we have
E6 and now Pawn to A3 so still not doing
anything with your C Pawn the shop
characters on C5 we have Knight beta D2
and now uh 11 castles and Hikaru lunges
forward with Ponte B4 attacks the bishop
here and uh he might have some ideas of
putting his own dark Square Bishop on
this long diagonal so here we have
Bishop to E7 and now uh there is the
game where Bishop to B2 was played but
here Hikaru strikes with Pawn to C4 and
it is now already as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game so what does
Lavon do well Hikaru has this beautiful
expansion on the queen side of course he
will try to undermine it pawn to A5 we
have B5 by Hikaru and the B6 now and
already you can see with this structure
if you can ever get something like C5
captures then already you get a nice
past B Pawn so here at Bishop to B2 we
have Bishop to B7 and Bishop to E2
Hikaru now ready to Castle we have
Knight B to D7 and uh Hikaru castles we
have rooked the C8 Rook to C1 both
players putting Rooks on the most
probable file to open up fairly quickly
and now Rook the C5 Lavon uh tries to
tries to lift his Rooks and also he
wants to clear the path for the queen he
wants to bring the queen over to A8 to
put pressure on this G2 pawn and the
problem is if you go for C characters on
D5 then you can play Bishop captures on
D5 any four captures then Levon could
capture with the bishop or with the
Knight and then well this does not look
all that great for hikar with the bishop
pair so excellently placed so after Rook
the C5 we have A4 he covered just uh uh
strengthens his B5 pawn and okay maybe
you can capture Levon goes back Rook to
C7 and now Knight to D4 uh we have
Knight to C5 with the pawn Advanced to
A4 uh level one figures and now it's a
Target he's gonna put his Knights the C5
and the queen is now stuck guarding that
A4 Pawn so Knights due to F3 the
captures on C4 finally we have a capture
and now Knights the E5 you're uh you can
always capture on C4 so uh no no point
in rushing that but what he car really
wants is put a knight on that C6 square
and okay Queen to A8 now putting
pressure on the G2 pawn and Knight D to
C6 and uh sorry Knight um D to C6 and
this is now a an excellent piece here
it's very hard to dislodge it EU can
capture ones but you don't really gain
anything with that so here uh Lavon goes
for Knight to D5 uh we have Rook
captures on C4 and now Pawn to F6
chasing away the knight from this
beautiful Central Square also you kinda
diminish the power of this bishop as now
it's not attacking G7 anymore and here
you probably are thinking of two things
moving the Knight something like Knight
to F3 and also you are considering
Knight captures on E7 and Knight
captures on E7 is very interesting
because after you capture this with
check uh how does black continue let's
say you play Knight captures on E7
there's this very nasty Queen to D6 move
attacking the rook and the pawn on B6
and after black plays Knight D5
defending the Rook the the pawn here now
you will play Rook captures on C5 and
after B captures Queen captures an E6 as
you have removed the defender of the E6
Pawn King h8 and not Knight the C4 you
have this beautiful full past B Pawn and
you have a very nice compensation for
the sacrificed exchange but Hikaru
doesn't go for Knight captures and E7
nor does he move the Knight back he
instead plays Bishop to G4 and this is
where the fun really begins because
there are so many possibilities here
that televon can play but he goes for
the for the strongest move and that is
to accept hikaru's challenge he plays F
captures on E5 and okay now Hikaru goes
for Rook captures on C5 so he just lost
the piece and now he gives up the
exchange what's the what's the point of
this well the bishop and G4 will at some
point pick up the E6 Pawn with the check
and he will win back some material so
here Knight captures an E3 by 11 and the
reason for this is well like we said if
B captures on C5 Bishop Bishop captures
an E6 check you will pick up that Knight
on D5 so better grab something uh you
know instead of just giving giving it up
for nothing so Knight captures an E3 Now
The Rook is attacked the queen is
attacked The Rook on C5 is attacked and
Hikaru goes for Knight captures an E7
with check Rook captures and now Queen
to D6 attacking that Rook on E7 Queen to
d8 offering a queen trade defending the
rook and now Bishop captures an E6 with
check by Hikaru King to each eight Queen
capture 78 Rook capture 78 and now F
captures an E3 leaving the rook and C5
to be captured B captures on C5 and now
I was uh so interested and fascinated by
this position because both players have
Five Pawns he carves sacrifice material
he's down the exchange but okay he does
have the bishop pair we always know how
strong the bishop pair is so I took
Meadow for a walk and I allowed the
engine to Crunch the numbers
it was able to Crunch the numbers still
depth 46 and or maybe 48 I don't know
which which was it but at depth 46 or 48
the engine evaluates this position as a
0.00 zero so that's uh absolutely
incredible and how nicely uh Hikaru
managed to get some play here but okay
he has a pass Pawn so does Lavon the
past C Pawn is also incredible and
Hikaru plays Bishop to C4 which is the
absolute strongest idea here the problem
is if you play something like Bishop to
B3 which maybe makes more sense then
Levon can just sacrifice the C for Pawn
to activate his Rooks let's say Bishop
captures on C4 Rook to C7 and once you
move the bishop Rook C is gonna go to C8
to cover the back Rank and this Rook is
now coming to D2 so there are many uh
active ideas here for black but like if
you go for Rook to F7 after the bishop
Rook the D2 sorry Rook to D2 goes after
this bishop and also threatens Rook
captures on G2 with check and the black
would solve all of his problems and
that's why Hikaru finds this absolute
brilliant Bishop to C4 not allowing
Levon to sacrifice the C pawn and
activate his Rooks because it's not
gonna be easy to activate the Rooks with
with the with the Bishop's pair so
active and notice that you can't
activate the Rook right away because
Rook death it will be Checkmate so here
Ponte H6 first by Lavon now getting rid
of any checkmating ideas and now Bishop
to C3 and now Hikaru covers D1 uh d2d4
D3 D5 everything in his half of the uh
the board is covered so you don't have
to worry about Levon using the D file
for his Rooks and if you can't use the
open file then the Rooks aren't all that
great so Bishop to E4 now Levon wants to
exchange the light Square Bishop which
will be very good for him and now Rook
the C1 by Hikaru interestingly you
cannot you can't really go after the A5
Pawn because if Bishop captures an A5
Rook A8 and then the bishop has to move
you lose the A4 Pawn so you don't really
gain anything Rook to C1 now Hikaru is
trying to get Levon to go for this um a
bishop to D3 idea but if you play Bishop
to D3 now then Bishop characters and A5
is is very strong because now the bishop
captures on C4 you will already have the
A4 Pawn defended and if you go for Rook
to A8 then uh you well you can go Rook
to A8 attack this bishop but then just
Bishop to B6 and now again what can you
play here if a bishop captures on C4
you're gonna play real characters and C4
the pawn is defended if you capture the
the pawn on A4 then Bishop captures and
D3 or Bishop is undefended so this would
be uh very very good for Hikaru so
that's why this uh Rook to C1 move is
very very tricky so Lavon goes for Rook
e to D7 he wants to trade Rooks with
Rook to D1 check and Hikaru doesn't
allow it Bishop act 82 now controlling
the D1 square with the bishop and his
Rook King to H7 Levon starts bringing
the key into the game now Pawn to H4
grabbing more space on the king Side
Pawn to C4 finally Levon finds a way to
get rid of that pawn
uh as Hikaru had to move the bishop and
then he will use the C file for his
Rooks but Hikaru not interested in that
pawn uh instead he goes for Pawn to H5
and notice that Hikaru can capture an E5
and A5 end on C4 but Hikaru doesn't uh
uh want any pawns he just plays H5 he
grabs more space on the king side limits
the movement of the black king and now
Bishop to D3 uh Hikaru declines the
trade Bishop F3 and now Levon should go
for Pawn to E4 but instead he goes for
Rook to F7 and this is where things
start to get really really interesting
and especially for uh for Hikaru as
Lavon is much much lower on time uh
Bishop captures on E5 by Hikaru we have
rooked the E8 now going after the bishop
and the bishop to D4 so why has Lavon
sacrificed the piece here uh it's uh
it's a very very deep indeed Pawn to G5
and now H captors and G5 by Hikaru as
this is a Blitz game I will briefly
mention that Bishop to D5 is winning
here for Hikaru but it's such a funky
line that you don't expect anyone to
play this in in Rapid time format in
Blitz time format for example Rook to f8
B6 now and after Rook the B8 defending
the pawn now you cap run C4 and after
Bishop captures on C4 Rook captures on
C4 uh you are uh well you are up to
pawns but also how is the The Rook to
stop this past Pawn if Rook beat the C8
for example
uh you wanna you wanna trade off that
Rook Rook the C7 check and I throw
characters on C7 B captures on C7
there's just no way to stop this bishop
B6 Bishop captures on A5 is coming
you're gonna win one more pawn and then
it's just two too many pawns if King
Jade are gonna play Bishop B6 and even
this is impossible because just Bishop
captures and then you can't capture
because of uh C Pawn queening so instead
after G5 he carplayed h Captain G6 Alpha
song King captures on G6 and King the F2
now we have H5 by 11 and now King to G3
uh and here uh with Bishop the E4 it's
still a very uh equal game for example
Bishop to E4 can be met with Rook
captures and C4 but then there's the
tricky H for move forward one and you
kinda get that white king into the
corner you can now trade everything
Bishop capture spawn captures real
captors and you have the two Rooks the
king uh it's not going to be easy
dodging everything with for that white
king but still white is up two pawns
it's still anyone's game and after King
to G3 instead King to G5 by Lebon and
now Rook the H1 and this is the only
move that gives Hikaru the advantage uh
the real idea is uh Rook H1 Rook the H4
and Rook to F4 fully activating the
Rooks but now after Rook to H1 he's also
attacking the pawn here uh so best for
for the one would be just the defended
let's say Rook to H7 and then like we
said you bring the Rook into the game
Rook H4 and if Bishop to F5 Rook to F4
uh he covers position would improve
tremendously but Levon as he was down on
time he went for the tricky Pawn to C3
which is uh just incredible and to give
you an idea what Levon wanted with the
C3 Pawn uh probably he uh if Hikaru
captures it then he probably didn't want
anything he probably missed that if Rook
captures any 3D car just goes behind the
rook and wins material but I think uh
what he did was why he did it was a bit
different because after C3 he carry did
go for Rook captures on H5 with check as
it was expected I mean they're playing
really quickly of course you go for real
characters on each five with check King
to G6 and now he was expecting Bishop
captures on C3 after which of course
will captures an F3 check wins the game
for Lavon after G captures The Rook is
now undefended but Hikaru of course saw
through this he played Rook to C5 and
now the pawn isn't really going anywhere
okay it's coming to C2 but it's never
touching C1 Hikaru played Bishop to H1
with check or if Levon wanted to stop
this he would have to give up the pass
Pawn so Bishop H5 King to H7 and now
Bishop captures on F7
uh grabbing the full Rook Rook the f8
hoping to get that Rook to F1 and then
promote his Pawn to a queen but now
Hikaru just played Rook to H5 and this
is now Checkmate as the bishop covers D
squares and the bishop covers the G7
Pawn so it's not like Levon missed mate
in one or anything he just had to try
something with his his position is
completely lost and then he was hoping
maybe something good good comes out of
this but nothing did uh so yeah very
nicely played by Hikaru winning this uh
game seven uh the the blitz section Was
Won by Hikaru he started by winning two
games then Lavon retaliated in the third
one but in the end the hikar won the
plus uh five plus one section here are
the the final results Hikaru one uh five
plus one uh with a score of five and a
half to two and a half then the three
plus one he car won again with five and
a half to three and a half and the one
plus one he car one with four and a half
to two and a half so winning in every
time format indefinitely
um a well-deserved the win and if you
are wondering what is next in the
speeches championship
this is what's happening so he covered
defeated Levon and he will be facing
nihal sarin in the semi-final as nikal
has defeated dingler with a with a
pretty uh great score 17-9 and uh in the
other half of the semi-final we still
have the quarterfinal between Carlson
and Carlson and um uh caruana and
between Wesley saw and Maxine vashiella
Graf so uh the thing that you all are
wondering yes a Hikaru Magnus final is
still possible but we'll see a lot more
a lot more games to be played by by a
lot of players for that to happen uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Hikaru
this game it was so great after uh you
know after the early skirmishes where
Hikaru just uh uh started going crazy
with this bishop to G4 move uh it was uh
like you could easily have this as a
classical game and you would not have
time to calculate everything that's
happening it's such a such a brilliant
position so well played by both of them
but in the end Hikaru out played him he
was faster and he managed to play the
position better but yeah regarding the
the position itself uh like this is a
classical chess Worthy uh we wouldn't
get it because we we wouldn't have this
opening but you know the position itself
yeah it would be great to have this in
classical game as well but yeah that's
the game I hope you guys um I enjoyed it
I would like to thank Logan Dobe Jeff
Graves Francis there Benjamin Richie and
Timothy Rosen for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and everything
else that happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day